i am joined live now by commissioner jim
gibson and commissioner thank you so
much i know you just got on the site so
you're kind of still kind of taking it
all in but tell me
a day like this it's so important to our
community to help heal what does it mean
to you
well this is
one of those times when you have a rush
of memory the things that affected you
on the day that
that we're all here to remember
it was
what struck me most about
as i thought about it is that i just
wanted to find a way to help
and i as i've talked to people hundreds
and maybe thousands of people over the
course of the the years that have passed
that's what was going on in everyone's
mind and and so when we think about
where we are today
we're
we're probably
far less united today than we've been
right
and that taught us that there is a way
for us to find what we have in common
and then work to try and do something
together to help one another and i i
think if there were anything that it
reminds me of it reminds me that we
found ourselves as a community
and now the struggle is to keep
ourselves together wow well that was one
thing that struck me was how well the
community came together in the moments
the weeks the the days and now the years
so before i let you go uh as far as the
planning goes this is quite an event and
it's so important to our community to
everyone
it really is i there's so much that
comes from remembering
remembering the people the individuals
the losses reminding ourselves that
there are still people that are
suffering intensely some physically
because they were injured others because
of the losses they've had others because
of the trauma that this brought into a
community's life it's important for us
to hail back to the things that are
really important and what was really
important then was each one of us and
the contribution we might make to
provide something of relief to another
being that community again commissioner
gibson thank you so much for your time
this morning
folks at home we have so much more
coming up as we prepare to mark this
very special very poignant very somber
day